what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
breaking down the backstory and the
unique powers and abilities of Chi Chi
Saki aka overhaul the main villain of my
hero academia season 4 I will explain
his secret past his true motivations and
his incredible OPIC work that looks like
something right out of Full Metal
Alchemist
if you end up enjoying this video and
you want to see more MHA content on the
channel please leave a like to let me
know and if you're new don't forget to
subscribe to anime uproar and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications heads up there will be
spoilers in this video specifically
around overhauls backstory and quirk but
not about what happens to him in the
story or the ending of the arc that
season 4 covers if that's ok with you
then by all means proceed but if you
don't want any information that the
anime has not yet covered proceed with
caution you have been warned when we
first meet overhaul he is a captain
within the Japanese mafia also known as
the Yakuza and he is also a leader of a
special group within the Yakuza called
GA Haase Kai or the eight precepts of
death we learned very quickly that
overhaul is a major germophobe
he hates dirty places and he thinks that
everyone around him is sick and filthy
this is why overhaul and the other
precepts wear those strange elongated
masks these masks were inspired by the
masks worn by plague doctors during the
plague outbreaks in Europe in the 17th
18th and 19th centuries the masks that
the doctors wore resembled the beaks of
birds and they were filled with various
aromas and perfumes because it was
believed that this would prevent the
doctors from contracting the disease
themselves and this is where the
inspiration for these masks of the
precepts comes from overhaul makes his
big move in the story right after all
for one is defeated by all might and
subsequently imprisoned overhall
believes that all for ones arrest left a
power vacuum within the criminal
underworld and he decides to step in and
become
the undisputed ruler of the Japanese
underworld overhaul will stop at nothing
to achieve his goals and he is willing
to destroy everyone who stands in his
way
be the heroes villains or innocent
civilians
however overhauls true motivations run
even deeper than simply becoming the
most powerful crime boss in Japan as a
child overhaul was taken in by the
former boss of the eight precepts of
death and raised within the Yakuza
overhaul was taught to adhere to a
strict code of honor that the Yakuza
follows including not hurting innocent
people or engaging in criminal
activities that the Yakuza considers
dishonorable overhaul felt a great deal
of loyalty towards the leader of the
eight precepts for taking him in and
taking care of him and he became
committed to the Yakuza and to defending
the honor of the Yakuza whenever it was
brought into question however although
the Yakuza was historically an extremely
powerful criminal organization within
Japan with its own strict set of rules
and codes of conduct with the appearance
of quirks and the emergence of the hero
society the Yakuza as an organization
began to decline heroes with opie
superpowers like all might brought
criminal organizations like the Yakuza
to their knees and by the time overhaul
came of age the Yakuza that he loved and
respected became just a shadow of its
former self the complete collapse of the
Yakuza became all but a foregone
conclusion nevertheless overhaul decided
that he could not allow this to happen
he became determined to bring the Yakuza
back to its former glory backed it away
it was before quirks appeared and
completely changed how Japanese society
functions in order to achieve his goal
overhaul decided that he must find a way
to eliminate all quirks from this world
so that things could go back to the way
they were and so that the Yakuza could
once again return to its rightful place
in Japanese society one of the theories
for how and why quirks appeared in the
first place states that quirks are a
genetic mutation that was spread to
humans in the form of a virus carried by
mice presumably the mice were used for
genetic experiments and these
experiments eventually led to the
development of quirks in
humans once the mice passed the virus
onto humans if this were the case it
would mean that quirks are actually a
form of plague on humanity being the
germaphobe that he is overhaul embraced
this theory as proof that quirks are a
disease a disease that has to be
eradicated
if overhaul can find a way to eradicate
all quirks then he can eliminate the
disease and coincidentally he can also
eliminate the major reason why the
Yakuza has been sidelined as an
organization if he can eliminate quirks
overhaul can achieve his dream of
restoring the Yakuza to its former glory
and restoring society to what it was
back before quirks appeared and changed
everything but despite his apparent
hatred for quirks and his determination
to find a way to destroy all quirks no
matter what the cost
overhaul just happens to possess one of
the strongest and most versatile quirks
in the entire MHA world the name of his
quirk is also overhaul and it allows its
user to disintegrate anything he touches
as long as he touches it with at least
one of his fingers he can kill someone
instantly by simply disintegrating them
and that is in itself incredibly opie
but that's not all
if overhaul chooses to reassemble
someone right after disintegrating them
he can actually bring them back to life
and he has done this before with some of
his underlings like roppa the user of
this quirk can actually control how much
of someone's body is disintegrated and
if he chooses not to kill someone but
merely break down parts of their body he
can then reassemble those parts and all
of the past injuries and illnesses
within that part of the body will be
cured that said this process of
destroying and rebuilding parts of
someone's body is very painful for the
person involved but even with that in
mind overhauls ability to reassemble
people and cure all of their illnesses
and injuries is unbelievably powerful
and useful the quirk overhaul can also
be used on inorganic matters such as
walls and earth allowing the user to
disassemble and reassemble the entire
battlefield around him in order to gain
an advantage over his opponents it's
basically like having home
advantage all the time everywhere and if
that wasn't enough if he disassembles
parts of his own body at the same time
as the parts of someone else's body
overhaul can actually reassemble them in
a way that essentially fuses the two
people together creating a fused and
more powerful version of overhaul when
he fuses with another person or persons
it doesn't even have to be just one it
can be more overhaul gains the ability
to utilize that person's quirk and other
abilities along with his own so once
again to call this quirk overpowered is
actually an understatement that being
said this work does have some drawbacks
overhaul appears to be incapable of
simply turning the quirk off so he has
to wear special gloves that allow him to
keep his power in check another drawback
of this quirk is that it appears to take
a physical toll on its user when using
his quirk overhaul tends to develop a
rash and itching nevertheless these
drawbacks are relatively minor when
compared to all the abilities that this
quirk allows its user to utilize such as
the ability to destroy and put back
together everything around him including
inorganic objects human bodies and even
his own body in terms of personality
however overhaul is not exactly a
mastermind like some of the other
villains in this series overhaul is
definitely ruthless and he is willing to
do whatever it takes to achieve his
goals including things that are
extremely cruel and inhumane such as
treating innocent civilians as pawns in
his criminal game he is even willing to
explicitly violate the Yakuza code of
honor against the wishes of his boss in
order to achieve what he believes to be
the greater good of restoring the Yakuza
to its former glory as such overhaul can
be extremely impulsive and prone to
angry outbursts which means that he is
not the most organized and plan oriented
villain in the world and this is
something that can be exploited by his
enemies and rivals
but with that I have given you the basic
setup for overhaul as a villain and the
unique properties of his overpowered
quirk without spoiling too much of the
plot for you having said that we cannot
fully understand overhauls character
without first discussing in detail the
character of arey if you would like me
to make an entire video
on Harry that explores her backstory her
true identity and her unique quirk be
sure to leave a like on this video and
comment down below that you wanna see
the Aerie vid if we hit 5,000 likes on
this video I will publish the area video
within a week of hitting 5,000 likes on
this one and that video will serve as
both a special video nari and as the
conclusion two overhauls character arc
if you enjoy this video and you want to
see more videos like it including the
area vid please leave a like to let me
know and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications if you don't make
sure to turn on all notifications the
way that YouTube works now you will miss
the majority of our videos it's just the
way it is so if you do want to get
notified when we publish another video
whether MHA or something else please
make sure to click that notification
bell and click to turn on all
notifications you can check me out on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest boku no hero news and
updates I want to give a big thank you
to all of our anime out pro patrons who
make videos like this one possible
special thank you to all of our pro hero
to your patrons including the one and
only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason
Wilson King's eldest on hell cruise
stealers poet Pablo
atropos Wraith very dolla beat karate
Gian Anatole Cassatt's ki TJ Nathaniel
and alpha do and I can't forget the ones
that rise above all other clans a
massive thank you to all of our the one
tier patrons including Ingrid ah alone
Adam Maddie Mac makoto-kun and you boys
Seth if you enjoy our videos and you
think that they add some value to your
life consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our page and exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
cowboys
[Music]